what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today because you guys
requested it we are going to look at the
entire life of William Vaughn Chet's
this is one of the most interesting
characters in the whole series in my
opinion so this should be a fun video if
you want to see more black clover on
this channel let me know by smashing
that like button if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss any new videos
let me know what other characters in
anime you would like to see a life of
video done for as usual there will be
manga spoilers you've been warned so
let's turn to the overpowered guy in the
mysterious mask in the anime right now
William Vaughn gence is only 26 years
old and yet he is already the magic
knight captain of the clover kingdoms
strongest and highest-ranking squad the
golden dawn squad as we are told early
on in the series he is the closest
person to being the next wizard king not
only did his squad take first place at
the Star Wars Festival they also
performed the best in the Royal Knights
selection exam at only 26 years old he
already stands at the head of the clover
kingdoms magic Knights only surpassed by
the wizard king julius nova chrono
himself but let's take a look at how he
got to this impressive point and what
happens to him afterwards
william was born the illegitimate son of
a certain noble he was called a cursed
child because he was born with scars all
over the top half on his head the scars
were permanent and not even magic could
fix them the people around him thought
he was creepy they were afraid of him
because of his appearance until he
turned eight he lived in the forsaken
realm so even though he had noble blood
he lived in the poorest region of the
clover kingdom for a large portion of
his childhood he was only brought to the
noble region when his father's
legitimate heir died only then was
William taken in as an aristocrat
however ironically things got even worse
for him when he moved to the noble realm
although his great world tree magic was
viewed as a curiosity the nobles still
hated looking at William scarred face
his father's lawful wife William's
stepmother was the worst she badly
abused her stepson it was a hellish
childhood according to William at the
age of 13 in the midst of all that pain
he met Julius Toma chrono while the
ladder was still the magic knight
captain of the grey Deer squad
unlike most people Julius didn't care
about Williams appearance he was just
awed by his magic power when William
used his world tree magic Julius could
sense that the young boys kindness was
trying to protect everything the captain
of the gray deer squad insisted that the
young William had to join the magic
Knights William was touched by Julius as
kindness but he felt like he couldn't be
a magic knight because of the ugly scars
on his head Julius was confused as if
Williams scars never even factored into
the equation he said that the scars were
nothing to worry about but he gave him a
mask the same ask you where's to this
day to make William feel better
Julius put a lot of work into making the
mask and his effort made William very
happy although William thought the mask
was very tacky right from the get-go he
decided to wear it proudly and to pledge
his grimoire to Julius service as
William mentions Julius was the first
person to see past the creepy scars and
recognize him for who he really was
two years later William turned 15 got
his grimoire and joined Julius is grey
Deer squad however there was something
else strange about William besides the
scar ever since he was a child he felt
like someone was sleeping inside him
this person was deeply hurt very angry
and at the same time very sad
William felt that he had to protect this
weak existence inside him he felt that
his own body was no longer just his own
and because of that he never felt truly
alone it was because of this presence
inside him that he could bear living
through his painfully lonely childhood
when he was around 9 years old he
started having dreams these dreams were
of elves they started with days of
happiness and ended with the seed
despair and hatred William always felt
like it was his life's duty to protect
this presence inside him and he felt
that more than ever when he saw their
dreams keep in mind this was four years
before he would meet Julius at the age
of sixteen after William had already
joined the great deer squad the presence
inside him awoke his name was Patri he
received his own grimoire and now
William was convinced that there were
two souls living in his body at some
point they gained the ability to switch
their souls and when poetry takes over
Williams body the curse scars disappear
because the human curse
no effect on the elf William felt like
it was his absolute duty to turn into
Patri who he considered a twin however
he was torn between this person inside
him and Julius his leader who showed him
kindness and believed in him when no one
else did Pachi ended up going by the
name Licht formed the eye of the
Midnight Sun and acted against Williams
country leader and friends all the while
William continued to perform his duties
as a magic knight he worked alongside
Yami for Julius's great dear squad then
after Julius became the wizard King he
allowed both Yami and William to create
their own squads Yami created the black
bulls and William created the Golden
Dawn according to William he wanted to
create the ultimate squad to repay
Julius for everything he's done for him
he wanted to create a squad that would
bring a golden dawn into the world and
disperse the Dark Knight as William
would explain later his mana guided him
to select skilled members of the Golden
Dawn squad he succeeded in creating the
strongest squad as thanks for all that
Julius has done for him eventually
William has to make a decision who will
he choose to side with his precious
friend Patri who wants to take down the
clover kingdom or his precious teacher
Julius who wants to save it in the end
he can't choose both helped him get
through his hellish childhood both were
there for him when no one else was so he
meets Julius at the royal capital he
tells him about poetry William says that
they will have to decide what's going to
happen among themselves before he
transforms into poetry so that the two
can battle Julius doesn't blame William
he believes that everything he did for
poetry was the result of his kindness
Patri and Julius go on to fight Julius
could have won the battle but he was
holding back likely because he didn't
want to kill William his precious
student and friend in the end Julius is
forced to sacrifice his own life to save
the people of the royal capital from
within his body William cries when he
sees the wizard King meet his end he
apologizes to Julius and congratulate
spa tree then according to poetry he
falls into an endless slumber whether
we've seen the last of William remains
to be seen but he has been an
exceptionally interesting character that
was associated with one of the biggest
twists in the series so far his name
was definitely a clue of what was to
come Vaughn jets is spelled almost
exactly like the word vengeance which is
exactly what Pachi was after he wanted
revenge he wanted to punish all humans
for what he thought they did to the
elves then there's also the fact that
people in mysterious masks are usually
hiding something but in the end it was
still an impactful reveal that provided
important characterization for William
his life was a living nightmare but
Patri and julius helped him make it
through his rough childhood and turn his
life around they were both the most
important people in Williams life and
they wanted completely opposite things
although most of us me included probably
tied with Julius it is important to keep
in mind that William viewed Patri like
his own twin brother even if he was
wrong for seeking revenge against humans
William couldn't bear to hurt him any
more than he'd already been hurt
remember that even before he met Julius
William empathize with potteries pain
and wanted to protect him like one would
want to protect a younger brother in the
end his kindness made it so that he
couldn't hurt anyone he had to stay
uninvolved and let the two most precious
people in his life resolve their
conflict by themselves Patri later comes
around he learns the truth of what
happened on that day so long ago and he
joins our heroes to take on one of the
most overpowered villains in anime if
William wakes up again he will no doubt
be happy about this transformation that
has taken place within Patri and I
really hope he does wake up because I
still feel like we haven't seen him go
all out with his World Tree magic yet
but let me know what you think is
William a good person can you understand
why he didn't tell anyone about Patri or
do you see him as a traitor who should
have sided with Julius and the kingdom
and never helped Patri I'm curious about
how you guys view this complicated
character and while you're in the
comments let me know which one of your
favorite anime characters you would love
to see a video like this done for this
one was suggested by you guys and I'll
probably be looking in the comments of
this video to get ideas for the next one
and that is it for today's video thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
the video make sure to smash that like
one to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell for more black clover
on this channel we have a whole black
clover playlist that is Khan
being updated so make sure to check that
out a big thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan and Jason Wilson and
are the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans a17 ffvp Steven and
Radha Maddy Mac 239 and Michael
kaldur'ahm if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon calm animals or and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these epic
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
see you space cowboys
[Music]